you are now live with layer eight culture
tech thursday what's up y'all it's tech
thursday back again another thursday with
layer eight culture so
Thursday.
Man, a lot has been happening this week.
So let's get right into it.
So it looks like Fable V is back.
I gotta be honest, I have some FOMO.
I did not renew my card subscription
because I'm a OpenAI ChatGPT fan,
even though
I'm a little skeptical after what happened
with Claude and the government,
and then I'll like them coming back.
But actually, let me share my screen.
That's what we'll do.
We'll share the window.
Make it easy.
Give me one sec.
So it dropped.
Was it yesterday?
Man.
I think, you know what,
I think I am going to,
I kind of don't want to,
but I think I am going to end
up getting back into Claude this year.
Oh, while I'm sharing,
let me do something real quick.
I want to make sure we're on Instagram.
Are we live on Instagram?
Let's see.
It says we are.
Let me verify that real quick.
Yep, so that's Claude.
Oh, sorry.
That's Fable Five by Anthropic is back.
Let's see what they're saying.
So our newest model tackles our newest
model.
Yeah, it's back.
It's the same model.
Well, it might be a little different.
biggest challenges,
fewer check-ins needed until July seventh.
You can use up to fifty percent of
your plans weekly usage limits on table
five.
Cool.
So you got a couple more days left.
You can continue on table five with usage
credits.
Learn more.
All right, so.
it's part of your paid subscription so
it's cool if you're on pro max team
let's see what's included again that fifty
percent web mobile everywhere okay cool so
we're back in it see it sucks because
my subscription
did not roll it over and it ended
like the twenty ninth of June so I
literally missed this you know what and
I'm gonna do it for the culture and
gonna sign back up this week and check
it out all right today we do have
on the Daniel from the deal the real
estate deal lab should be joining us so
We'll discuss, we'll kind of explore,
look at different things until he logs in
and joins us.
But let me check something here.
So I'm in.
I'm not live.
All right, real quick, let's fix this.
Cool, so Instagram.
Hey guys, thanks for joining.
I'm trying to make sure I'm logging into
Instagram.
We are just looking at Claude.
I keep saying Claude.
Fable five.
So I will commit to getting Fable five
This upcoming week.
Even though I love OpenAI.
GPT-Five.
Five.
I do feel like this was a conspiracy.
Because.
Oh that's another thing we got to look
up.
OpenAI is about to drop.
GPT-Five.
Six.
Which is supposed to be.
Equivalent to.
Our dear friend FableFive.
So.
Just so happens that.
government shuts down fable five that's
kind of redacted from the ethos and then
open ai announces that they're making
headway with their mythos competitor gpt
five point six and then all of a
sudden comes back so i do expect within
the month gpt five point six to drop
and uh of course
I'll be using it because I kind of
like OpenAI,
even though I don't agree with all their
business practices.
But that's neither here nor there.
All right,
so I'm trying to get this Instagram up
and running.
So I'm not sharing that screen,
but we're going to figure this out.
Because I do like having Instagram Live.
Last week we did Instagram live.
I feel like there's a lot more
interaction.
People popping in, popping out.
So why not?
All right.
So set this up.
Almost there, people.
Put this out.
And let's see if this works now.
So I use StreamYard.
And StreamYard is really cool.
But Instagram integration.
Wouldn't say it's the best.
It's kind of,
you got to set it up and then
you got to go live on Instagram.
Let's try one more thing here.
i'm gonna save that okay we should be
good and then if i click this okay
i think it's loading now yes see it's
built there we go we're on instagram now
cool
Wasn't that hard?
Yes, it was.
It was a little difficult, but we're live.
All right.
So back to what we're talking about.
Table five.
Hold on.
Let me.
Let me give myself a setup properly.
There we go.
All right, we're good now.
Okay.
So that's available five next week.
People will explore that.
So if we go to GPT five point
six, my keyboard is off.
All right, here we go.
So what are they saying about five point
six?
Yeah, six days ago.
So.
It's pretty it's pretty funny because.
As you get close to the sun.
You're going to get burned.
But it's called soul.
So five point six.
So strongest model yet.
They've already got previews of.
kind of those benchmarks, scores.
Wow.
Ooh, they got Fable V there.
Ooh, look at that.
Claude Fable V. I remember Claude Mythos.
That's the one that they were basically
saying, we cannot release this.
So instead of Mythos V,
they released Fable V.
so gpt is saying our open ai is
saying that so this gpt five point six
is actually scoring better than uh quad
mythos and then gpt five point six soul
ultra is scoring nine point one wow insane
and this terminal bench um
I'm guessing they run different,
they throw different problems at it from a
terminal level.
So that's like your cloud code,
your Cobot CLI, that type of stuff,
not your like chat stuff.
But here we go.
So token usage, that's remember people,
everyone's going to the token,
so it's going to cost you.
to use these models.
I keep telling everybody yesterday's price
is not today's price.
Let me fix something in the stream here.
Let me fix this for the people.
That's not what I wanted.
More of a mess and stuff live.
It's all right.
wanted like uh is it this layout why
is it doing that that's how i'll mess
with that later i don't know why it's
doing that
sorry i will leave it okay so back
to what i was saying so five point
six so seems to be better it is
definitely more expensive uh that's that's
given it's gonna happen the price of ai
is gonna go up up up up up
Because right now,
we're basically at a point where AI is
subsidized.
So we talked about this before,
but AI models require your data.
So it requires usage for it to become
better.
And as you use it more,
the models become better.
AI companies can charge more.
those better models all right so again for
your ai news definitely check out um our
instagram because the automation is in
effect people so i talked about the
automation last week like all of this is
ai generated
It's very on-brand.
And we'll talk a little bit about the
social media aspect of this.
What I did come to realize is that
the cost behind this is pretty expensive
over time.
So I've been exploring more cost-effective
ways because, again, this is like mixed.
This is like very,
it's a lot of content.
It's like this is like pre-launch of Layer
A culture.
We did some like super basics.
countdown stuff.
Very basic.
This is how we evolve.
We got to put stuff out there.
We got to execute, analyze, repeat.
So then we got into the AI video
stuff.
And now we're creating a lot more,
as you can see,
a lot more consistent content here.
I did the calculations.
I'm
plan to push that pushing out about a
hundred and twenty different pieces of
content per month that's a lot think about
it and then on top of that like
we talked about the process behind this so
leveraging not only because the thing is
these can't go through the chat GPT
interface these have to go straight to the
open
OpenAI API.
And then you're pulling images out of GPT
image two.
You're using Sora two for the video,
like the reels by that Sora two.
And then for the text,
we're actually using
I think it's FFmpeg.
It's a open source GitHub repo.
So cool, open source means free.
So we use that and that's how we
have the super consistent text.
There's a markdown document where we talk
about,
where we talk about the actual brand voice
and brand guidelines.
So like the electric blue,
that's on brand.
you know, the aesthetic, I should say,
that is all part of the brand.
So that's why we get really consistent,
but then different pieces of content.
I did take out the,
I used to have a watermark.
I was like, oh, that's cool,
that's hilarious.
I was like, no,
that looks kind of lame.
I don't like,
I'm very particular about aesthetics.
So I was like, no,
that's kind of lame.
Let's keep it out.
And what I do like is a carousel
so being able to go through that's dope
and then the carousel always man it's a
lot all right here we go carousel always
ends with uh larry culture so that's how
you and then of course like the brand
speaks for itself eventually once you see
you know oh that's larry culture just goes
off of the brand and what it looks
like so that's the point of having that
social media presence
And that's all automatic, people.
The cool thing about that,
remember I talked about the whole thing of
having your AI not only produce but also
analyze, self-heal, self-like.
I've been doing a lot of that this
past week.
So even with this social media content
engine is what I call,
I do have it actually assess on a
weekly basis what's being put out,
what's working,
what's resonating with people.
and then repeating a lot of that i
have a cool concept that's dropping
tomorrow and it's going to be a carousel
where we talk about what is an mp
mcp how do you use it it goes
to a quick guide on the website and
actually i'll show you the guide i'll give
you a preview of the guide so what
happens in this what happens is the
carousel tells you like hey um
Here's some quick information on MCP.
If you want more, comment MCP uses N-N-N,
which is like open source automation
Zapier.
So it pulls the trigger that connects to
Facebook Meta.
And as you comment MCP on the post,
reaches back out to N-N-N,
triggers the automation in Meta.
or Facebook, Instagram,
to provide that user a message with a
link to the AI field guide.
And this AI field guide, of course,
is AI-generated, eight-minute read.
You could save it.
The URL is right there.
You could bookmark it.
And it basically is just like a quick
guide on what an MCP is, like literally.
Boom.
how to use it.
We got resources, you know,
repos you can use.
These are clickable,
actual GitHub repos you can go to.
And you're on the Layer Eight Culture
website, which is like,
why would you want to be anywhere else?
It's a pretty cool website.
So if you haven't seen it,
definitely check it out.
You know, our main sponsor, Fabflow.
Shout out to Fabflow.
for supporting the culture.
And so that's dropping tomorrow.
I'm really excited.
I was able to kind of run through
the process so I could actually preview
the post, the concept, verified it,
and now it's just a live test.
And once I do the live test,
that's something I'll probably do on a
weekly basis.
Maybe not weekly.
Weekly's a lot.
I might do the guide thing like bi-weekly
because
I want to make sure I'm not just
pushing out random guides.
I feel like MCP is a very important
concept.
People throw this word around a lot,
and a lot of people are like,
what is that?
So I built a guide that kind of
really breaks down what the MCP is.
And then, of course, you can bookmark it,
and you can reference it.
It's got great resources.
We should probably do a video on what
an MCP is as well.
I'll make sure we do that in the
future.
all right so that is the n eight
n n eight n that's the name of
the open source actually let's look it up
right now so and again so your github
repo a lot of times when you're
interacting with uh open claw cloud code
github copilot cli you could let it know
like hey i don't know which
know github repos to use but for this
use case for this problem that i'm trying
to solve for if you could recommend a
github repo that would be great and it
will actually go through uh github well if
you definitely if you use github copilot
cli it's correct it's called man my words
today it's connected directly to github so
it can scan github very quickly and pull
up the top repos and what happens is
basically what people are providing for
you software
And a lot of people favorite it by
adding a star.
I can start and then boom,
you can see the rating goes up.
So you have one hundred ninety five
thousand stars for this repo.
Normally,
if you scroll down to the bottom here,
the read me, I guess a read me.
But you could actually.
A lot of this is a visual.
It's not just text,
so a lot of times people put like
screenshots to make it easier to read.
And this is what it is.
So any end.
You do have to set it up on
a computer.
So whether it's your local computer that
stays on because it has to be on
to actually run it.
So what I do is I put mine
on a virtual server or virtual VM that
sits in the cloud.
We talked about that before.
It's basically always on.
So I don't have to worry about my
actual computer being on.
And then I have set it up to
run locally.
I did not even have to go in
to the user interface and do all this.
Of course, you can configure it manually,
but when you have the power of cloud
code or a CLI or AI,
you can basically just tell the AI, like,
hey, set this automation up using N-A-N,
and it creates the connection between your
meta
Because Meta uses API to speak to your
Instagram, Facebook.
And then it also sets the trigger to
provide that, what do you call it?
That URL, that message.
Say, hey,
here's the link to the MCP AI field
guide.
Cool.
So, again, GitHub repos, basically,
there's so much free stuff out there.
Be careful.
Make sure that the repo that you're using
is reputable.
Normally, by the star rating,
you could definitely tell how good it is.
And, of course,
a lot of these very popular repos,
they'll have videos online.
People will use them.
definitely lots of uh information out
there but yeah like why go to zapier
when you can use nn like let's click
on any and again there's a website and
i believe they do have like a cloud
service so yeah they can they have the
free one where you could just put it
on your local host or your local um
server but then if you want to let's
say you don't have a vm or a
server you could pay for their enterprise
plan and basically all they're doing is
just putting that same instance on a vm
that they own so twenty bucks a month
you can have one project which people down
may know that i'm saying man that does
not make any sense
like because the thing is with the nan
on my on my server that i have
is open source i'm not stuck with just
one project i have multiple projects
running uh so yeah it's a great business
model i'm sure people are paying but you
don't have you don't got to pay for
it so why why do that all right
so if you look at like zapier which
is the equivalent to
NAN but like more of a premium paid
version does the same thing the cost is
of course it's a little more reputable you
know you get support I mean that's what
you're paying for right a lot of times
I can't even see that's the thing like
look at this stuff I can't even go
to like it's not even going to tell
me how much it costs contact sales
I can't even see the price.
There we go.
Yeah, dig for it.
Look at that.
There's the pricing breakdown.
Okay.
So Zapier is free.
You get a hundred tasks a month.
I mean, I think you are still, yeah,
so you're still limited.
So webhooks,
the stuff that actually really matters,
you're going to have to pay that nineteen
ninety nine a month.
to really have like through automation.
And then this is like enterprise grade.
Yeah.
For your enterprise stuff,
maybe see like that's your technical
account manager.
But this is like enterprise.
This is way beyond sixty nine dollars a
month.
But even here at sixty nine,
you do get priority support.
So that's something if you're going with
like a reputable enterprise grade
solution.
That is really what you're paying for
because that support goes beyond just you
searching online.
You could actually pull up a live chat,
talk to someone, email back and forth,
get problems resolved.
And then here you have priority support.
So that's really what you're paying for,
having that person there or that expertise
that can help you through issues.
But here at Layer A Culture,
We build in public,
so we help each other.
We build.
That's the whole concept.
All right, cool.
So back to what I was saying.
That's what's dropping tomorrow on the
social media stuff.
We're going to test that out,
see how it works.
Super excited about how that's going to
roll out.
So let's check real quick.
Ah, man,
we don't have Nathaniel from the Real
Estate Deal Lab.
It's all good.
We will continue.
So what I wanted to show,
I've been working with Nathaniel from Real
Estate Deal Lab,
and a lot of people don't know I
actually have a very strong business
background,
aside from my technical background.
So I pride myself on understanding how
businesses are supposed to function A to
Z, because I have an MBA,
and I actually use it.
my day job.
So I understand A to Z how a
business should function,
but then I also understand the tech stack
on top of that and how we can
accelerate, optimize, make things better.
So I've been working with Nathaniel from
Real Estate Deal Lab.
We got his site looking really nice,
real clean.
He's got great advisory services.
So if you're interested in investing,
real estate he's your go-to guy he's a
great advisor he's done it himself for
over ten years and he really wants to
give back and really help others
understand real estate investing from a
land commercial and real estate
residential standpoint so he's got this
thing called real estate deal lab and we
were kind of ideating on kind of how
does he create that funnel from
You know, getting people engaged,
letting them understand the value.
And I basically watched him for a little
bit.
I started to analyze these deals.
I found it pretty profound and cool on
how he analyzes deals.
It's like the way he breaks it down,
the way he looks at,
he finds the data.
Because I do the same thing, you know,
my approach a lot of times.
I look for the data.
I look for what's there.
And then I, of course,
add my point of view.
so that brought me to come up with
the deal analyzer so this is what we
talk about when we say providing value to
our customers out the gate so a lot
of times on these websites will have like
a form say contact me for quote contact
me for XYZ right how about a calculator
now this is all AI generated it's just
the arm
Is it Python?
It's JavaScript, I believe.
But don't worry about it.
It's AI generated.
Like, literally, it was like, hey,
create a investment calculator.
And I showed Nathaniel,
and he started playing with it.
He's like, oh, this is awesome.
Like, the numbers made sense for him.
The inputs made sense.
So let's say you have some type of
deal that you're thinking about.
Hey, I'm going to invest in this.
I'm not quite sure.
You know,
I'm going to do a fix and flip.
The purchase price is,
let's say the purchase price is just
pretty nice, right?
In this market, that's pretty nice,
one ninety, right?
And then after repair value,
let's say after you repair the unit,
your value is going to be at like
two seventy five, right?
pay the rehab costs let's say you're gonna
put what twenty thousand in it i don't
know i'm throwing these numbers now i'm
not i'm not nathaniel y'all so i'm just
saying i'm gonna hold it for i'm just
throwing numbers out here let's say i hold
it for a year right now i want
to fix and flip so let's say six
months i want to hold it for and
the monthly cost of me holding is what
uh yeah
Let's say it's that.
Whoa.
That bearded took over.
There we go.
All right.
And then you got your selling costs at
eight percent.
So leave that flat.
Down payment.
Leave that flat.
OK.
So this says this is a solid deal.
I'm projected to profit twenty six
thousand.
If I sell for twenty seven thousand nine
point five percent margin.
This is good data.
So I said, all right, man,
this is a solid deal.
But again, I'm still like, oh, no,
maybe this is my, you know, first,
second investment.
Guess what?
I reach out to Nathaniel.
I put in my name, email, phone number.
That sends off the email to Nathaniel.
He sees your deal.
He reaches out.
He contacts you.
So what I'm trying to say is,
This does not only apply to the real
estate deal lab.
Every industry has a calculator,
whether you know it or not.
So we're going to pick a random industry.
Let's see.
We do roofing.
Roofing calculators.
Roofing cost calculator, in some quotes.
We build that,
we put it on your site,
and it's no longer a backend processing
thing.
It's a like, right then, right now.
For the customer.
And doesn't, like, you don't have to put,
say, hey, there's a direct,
you don't have to give them a direct
quote.
You can say, hey,
We have your quote, it's ready.
There's tons of different ways from a
business standpoint,
you could think about it, but the idea,
again,
is we want to be able to provide
value immediately to the customer.
And then we follow through with your
expertise.
So leverage AI.
I think that's what we're going to see
in the industry moving forward,
like just in the world moving forward,
is that if you leverage AI,
you're able to put the mundane stuff
aside, automate a lot of that,
and then focus on being the expert,
having a point of view because you have
more data, you can move more faster,
speed to execution is just there,
and then you provide your expertise.
So that is the deal analyzer.
This is something I definitely wanna
scale.
not just deal analyzer,
but the concept of providing value.
I got some ideas, y'all.
Got some ideas from the AI standpoint.
Like I said,
cost is a big issue that a lot
of people don't think about when it comes
to AI.
What up, Bob?
I see you.
See you there in the chat.
So cost is a huge thing that people
aren't thinking about.
Like, how much am I spending on AI?
Like,
I don't think about it that much,
as much as I should.
Yeah, I got my twenty dollars a month,
but there's a lot of API calls that
I'm doing back and forth constantly.
That's costing me money.
So I'm not spending thousands a month,
but I'm spending hundreds of dollars a
month on AI.
And if you implement at the scale that
I'm positioning, I'm telling you to,
to really take advantage of it,
that cost can add up.
So it's something you do need to monitor.
So I do want to,
I'm going to work on some type of
report or calculator and I'll put it on
Larry Culture probably in the next two
weeks.
That's going to show you kind of what
the cost to implement certain solutions at
scale and what that looks like.
All right, next subject.
Let's get into the fun stuff.
So if we go back to
the content.
As Fablo said, the brand is on point.
And it truly is.
And if you want on-brand this type of
quality, it's going to cost,
but guess what?
I can do it.
I can definitely do it.
I can streamline it for you.
Run a campaign.
We build your brand.
We make sure it's solid.
We make sure your presence is there
online.
Another thing that's very important a lot
of people are missing out on is that
when search engines go out they're looking
at your brand like you could do certain
queries now say hey what layer a culture
is google will understand google
understands the aesthetic of layer culture
visually which is pretty important signal
as far as um
where that industry is going as far as
how information is indexed on the internet
very important to know and it does flow
into this subject so again i'm averaging a
hundred and twenty pieces of content per
month for this at this quality that can
be very expensive you're talking about at
minimum
hundred plus dollars so hundreds of
dollars per month just to build content
now my time is very valuable so for
me it's worth it um that's something you
have to think about as a business owner
is it worth it for you to invest
versus diy so tonight we'll get into diy
because like i said it before i do
like to do things the hard way just
so i can know like hey
I did it the hard way,
now let's do it, make it easier.
So I do like to do that.
So again, my tool of choice is ChatGPT.
Brace yourselves,
because I still haven't cleaned up my
ChatGPT like I've said everyone,
like I've told everyone to.
Like, yeah, it's a mess.
My chats are everywhere.
I've been working at the Real Estate Deal
Lab,
so like Nathaniel's stuff is like pinned
in here, which is cool.
So like his stuff is in a folder,
doesn't mess with my data.
So we'll talk a little bit about that
process.
How it kind of helped them form this
brand.
You see how it's very clean,
it's very on point.
From site to site,
you know the colors are there,
the font is there, everything is on brand,
and that's on purpose.
Like even when we did the stream stuff,
very consistent.
This is all ChatGPT stuff,
and it's pretty consistent.
No,
it's not perfect as the lyric culture is,
Again, that's the premium you pay for.
But we could get consistency with ChatGPT.
So we go here.
We're in the Daniels space.
First thing I did was we took,
he had flyers.
He had other social media posts.
He had a previous website with pretty good
details.
And he had a couple of images.
So like a handful of files that we
started with.
I loaded that in here.
I'm trying to see if we have,
let's see if we have the first, yeah,
so logo creation.
I think that was the first thing I
dropped in.
So we had like his images,
the logo that he had, like we quickly,
quickly developed
the website mock-up.
So like, if you look from there, actually,
you know what?
I'm,
I'm not being a hundred percent honest,
y'all.
When we worked with Nathaniel, we,
I'm trying to think, oh, you know what?
I think we use cloud.
No, we didn't here.
So where's that file?
It might've been one of these.
Cause we did have a couple different
options, I believe.
As you can see,
he brought a lot of information in.
Yeah, we did the website brand analysis.
There we go.
So we analyzed like everything he had as
far as like social media,
his current website,
all the flyers and stuff he had.
We built out the voice and tone brand
voice and tone.
And, like, guys, this is, like,
one prompt, literally.
I'm redesigning the website.
Please do a full analysis of the site
and give that my typing is off.
And give what you know about the Real
Estate Deal Lab.
And give me what you know about the
Real Estate Deal Lab.
No, it's not off.
Please provide a full recommendation on
brand, voice, and tone.
Simple.
So simple, y'all.
One prompt gave me all this.
Now, mind you, I did load the files.
So within this folder,
I did upload all the files as well.
But provided, and you can see right here,
his actual file that's referencing.
So I had a text file with the
list of his social media contacts.
Super simple.
Add the website.
And it gave me all of this.
This is a whole,
you can charge for this by itself, people.
That's a very detailed report off of one
prompt.
So we got tons of data to work
with.
We got like copyright style.
That's about how you word things as a
business.
Like you want to be very consistent.
You want to be very to the point.
What's your call to action?
All that fun stuff.
recommendation on your hero page your hero
page is like your home page that main
page kind of what's a strong tagline is
call to action join the lab watch the
deal breakdown he does a weekly stream on
every wednesday um his proof bars his
experience very prevalent like everything
is there so then
Prompt number two,
give you a recommendation for a premium
brand.
Please provide three image mock-ups.
So I always tell people like,
don't just ask CatchyPT,
but you got to be authoritative.
You have to tell it like, hey,
if you want five mock-ups,
it'll give you five images.
If you want six, it'll give you six.
So I'm saying all this for a reason.
So we had like different images.
And then from there,
I think I kind of stopped CatchyPT.
I went over to my,
level three AI model.
So my level three AI model is definitely
more, is a more detailed analysis.
And I compared them against each other.
I presented the pros and cons of each
solution to Nathaniel.
and we both agreed hey we're going to
go with this one it's a premium feel
it has the information we want yes
everything is not like perfect but super
simple and we took that just like we
showed you last week you go from the
mock-up you load that into the
you develop the website,
you adjust as needed,
and then you're good to go.
So that's what we did with Nathaniel.
And now we're going to talk a little
bit about creating some content.
So let's say Nathaniel,
and this actually is an issue,
a problem that he has that he wants
to solve for.
And that is the ability to create strong
content.
presence social media content and then of
course have it automated so what i did
propose with nathaniel was to spend you
know a set amount of time per week
going through what i'm about to show you
so let's open up a new chat real
quick same folder let's do new chat
just say i'm all from freestyling the show
because i do this but not as much
within here so i like to oh actually
i already did it oh man i love
when it happens not that but i love
when um because i already did this boom
super i don't have to freestyle this
people
Please create five different samples for
social media content style we can use for
the Real Estate Deal Lab.
Please create some reference images.
Boom.
So here's some content we're thinking for
the Real Estate Deal Lab.
I really love this one.
I did actually talk to Daniel about this
stuff.
I really like this one because it uses
like a real image.
And then it's like, hey, there's duplex.
It looks like,
and it's so weird how this is like
a Florida type of aesthetic.
He's based in Florida.
So it's like, it's Florida.
It's duplex off market.
They're asking to ten estimated after
repair value of three twenty five.
The question.
Would you buy it?
Comment your max offer.
Oh, this is perfect.
All right, so cool.
So we say...
we will do, yeah.
So paste this image in.
So copy, paste.
So when you paste the image,
like when you're working with images,
it's important that if you want to modify
or use like the same format that you
paste the image in.
I have noticed that sometimes if you paste
it in,
it's not that good of a quality of
what you're getting back.
So pro tip,
download the image because so what happens
was when you download the image you get
a higher resolution so you get a lot
of more detail in there so you download
the image go back here because you don't
want to edit that image you want a
brand new question you upload it so now
it has the full file with full context
you can say like
take this concept from one post to
carousel and people don't judge me I still
don't know how to spell carousel I've been
like I need to look up the full
spelling spell it correctly but chat
understands
two carousel of seven images with the same
brand and tone all related to the same
topic article.
So these
i just realized what i asked it to
do seven images it's gonna take a minute
so if you do four images less time
but again it's gonna create four images so
and guys i'm just on the twenty dollar
month plan like it's not something crazy
here so let's see
it's working it's working and again if you
don't know what a carousel is it's when
you go into instagram and you have like
multiple images or videos and you like
click the arrow button and like the last
one's always like the call to action like
hey if you like more save this or
hey follow or hey go to this link
or hey comment down below like it's always
call to action so we can shoot the
carousel let's see what it does maybe if
it does the call to action that would
be cool
if it doesn't we could definitely build
that in but this is something you can
do let's see what the let's see the
not the different images because again if
you scroll up here like even these images
the brands it isn't consistent but i did
ask i did ask it for samples of
different styles so we could probably ask
for more consistent groupings in the
future
Maybe it's time for me to update to
more availability because chat GPT has
been a little slow, people.
I'm glad I didn't ask for seven images.
But then again, like, that's the thing.
I miss money.
So there we go.
I mean, not too bad.
Look at that.
Oh, not too bad.
Shoot.
This is really good.
So, like,
notice it does one out of four.
Two out of four.
See, that's where the inconsistencies are.
The placement of the numbers.
Like, that's different.
Three out of four.
I mean, it's cool and all.
all for more until breakdown see this is
decent you're very consistent all right
I'll take it you could you literally take
those save those see the branding on the
logo is consistent up there
And then you want to be careful with
using faces because then that's difficult
to stay consistent.
um and the idea from a marketing
standpoint is to you utilize all these
images and that consistency but then you
still want to do organic stuff you still
want to get your phone out have your
video have your face record yourself all
that fun stuff but then you minimize
minimize that by having this content
that's going out all the time and of
course like if you need help
um with your description just ask like hey
again like copy these down into your so
like do this literally copy image paste it
in there you can copy this image paste
it in here and then you can ask
it like hey provide me a description of
this carousel post i don't know why mine
is was this not working
Oh, my bad, I know what I did.
All right,
so you could paste multiple images in.
It's not like a thing that I messed
up on.
But you could paste multiple images in and
then ask it for a description for your
post and you could do all that DIY.
It's okay.
So next prompt is,
I'd like other from other images.
my typing is off y'all post on this
social provide four images on different
topics but the same brand
and voice slash tone i'm making this up
all on the fly y'all i'm making this
up all on the fly but chat understands
me and that's why i like chat gpt
telling y'all chat gpt is for the streets
called an anthropic that's uh that's
oxford
And every now and then you do need
a little Oxford, you know,
but I had to keep it real street
in my AI approach.
Guys, I just realized something.
You can schedule this stuff out.
And again, like you could also,
because you're working in this project
folder, you can have multiple chats going.
So let's say,
you want to do multiple images,
kind of set it and come back to
it.
You could do like, all right,
this one's going to be my carousel.
This one,
another chat is going to be for one-off
images.
Another one's going to be for like another
image I want to do.
You could separate them by topics.
You could do all the little fun stuff.
but we did paste the reference image in,
that's gonna be important.
Put a reference image in,
you're gonna get better consistency.
And we should see something that's very
similar to this image and this style,
but different topics.
Should be four,
and that's four more posts.
That's the fifth post I have here in
the carousel.
can still use that this post up here
so that's technically six posts that we're
creating okay boom we got a result y'all
we got results look at this three races
structure deal oh this is awesome rental
deal check wholesaling one-on-one
Oh, I know what it did.
You know what?
It still did the carousel approach,
but the idea was to use these separately.
I think you still could get it.
Well, the thing, okay,
so this is still a carousel,
three-way structure deal.
It's okay.
This is doable.
This is usable.
consistency is still there but you see i'm
talking about people like very consistent
this is twenty dollars a month so two
carousels three posts three yeah that's
three posts because we have this post here
we could do the carousel and then we
could do another carousel
Carousel will be more of a premium post,
I would say.
So mix it up.
Do the single post, do a carousel,
do a reel.
You could do some varieties there.
But get the concept, people.
Stay consistent.
I see a lot of AI flyers that
are just way too much information.
Even this, like this right here.
Not too bad.
I would say this is borderline.
This one.
I don't see it's good.
Like look at the font.
Visually, if you're on a cell phone,
like you got to think about the user
experience, right?
You can't have things that are like super
small.
So you got to keep the font certain
size, which is really good here.
And visually,
you always tell it's AI when you have
the emoji icons in there,
but there's a difference in quality.
It's there when the icons are a set
color.
It's a much better experience.
So I just proved it, y'all.
it's possible to get consistent on-brand
imagery in your twenty dollar a month chat
gpt plan we did it in what ten
minutes and we have three quality posts um
of course if you go on especially if
you're it's your business you have the
expertise you can go out you can ask
like okay
Okay,
give me the topic ideas for Instagram
posts.
You don't have to know you don't have
to be the expert as we're not telling
don't ask AI tell AI.
Let's tell AI Hey, boom.
Okay, perfect.
Now,
As we wrap up,
I'm just going to show you these great
images for your top five nations on topics
using this same brand voice tone.
All right, cool.
We're just going to cook.
We did, what, three?
So we're about to do five more.
All right.
So again, you get really consistent stuff.
This is something I really am passionate
about as far as businesses.
So I'm going to... Let's do this first.
Let's take this out.
We'll remain...
safe here let me go to what is
it so i found this group on facebook
and it's a lot of like small business
owners of course a lot of them are
using uh ai
To create their content.
Flyers.
So on and so forth.
So I do want to do like a
reaction thing.
Where I'm reacting.
On.
What people are putting out.
So here we go.
So like.
Luna Days Cafe.
This is AI.
Like this isn't too bad though.
Like the font size is pretty good.
But then again, from post to post,
like there's definitely some things that
I'm noticing.
So like Loombar, not too bad.
This is a good one.
Way too much information, people.
We're just putting too much information on
these flyers.
We got to, that's the thing with AI.
We get so much information.
It's important that we dial it down.
and just have like a really clear call
to action.
Like this should be in the comments,
like a link instead of having the QR
code.
Just have a link like comment after you
post.
Here's the link.
I click on it.
I'm good to go.
Like just going through,
it's like I'm very intrigued by what
people are doing.
And of course, like,
not all these are bad.
Like, here we go again.
Boom.
Perfect example.
Way too much information.
Like, way too much information.
This is really small.
Like, what is the call to action?
Like, the most important thing.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, all right.
So we know, like, where to go.
Did they...
Yeah, we gotta put the links in the,
we gotta put some type of link in
the, uh, the comments.
Oh, we got Nathaniel.
Yeah.
Hi.
Hey, what's going on, man?
Good.
I,
I got the camera here and this has
nothing to do with anything and I'm still
trying to figure out how to put this,
this, uh, mount up here so I could.
Oh, the mount.
Yeah.
So that just, I forgot the way,
cuz I have it on, on a tripod,
but the logo.
The YOLO Live logo faces towards you.
And then the folding part folds.
The camera just sits on it because it's
magnetic.
And the folding part actually folds up and
down.
So it's also a logo.
It's really small.
Let me see where you're at.
Oh, this is a tripod part, obviously,
right?
Yes, bottom.
Yep.
But it doesn't even have a... Oh, okay.
So this is... Okay, let me see it.
Magnetic, yeah, yeah.
I promise, folks,
I'm not this slow normally.
Okay.
Still playing around with this thing.
Now I need to just transfer it over.
Yeah, actually, we'll meet up tomorrow,
so we'll...
We'll get all hooked up for you.
Okay.
All right.
Good.
Oh, well,
you guys are going to suffer with low
quality camera, but this is the last time.
Nice.
And I had to go grab it.
Well, it was a process.
No problem, no worries.
So yeah, I agree.
And sometimes when I'm creating flyers or
whatever, there is a lot of information,
but it's like,
what's the real information that should be
there?
Yeah, exactly.
And then this is me looking at it
on a computer screen.
Imagine me looking at this on my phone.
It's way too small.
But hey, I come with presence.
Check this out, man.
We were...
We've been cooking.
Hey, man,
we've cooked up like six pieces of social
media content for you.
Nice.
The last fifteen minutes.
So we'll go over it real quick.
So remember I showed you this as an
example with ChatGPT.
So I took that and expanded it out
to a carousel model and said, hey,
one prompt,
make a carousel of four images.
So now that one image turns into,
you scroll, part two,
scroll part three part four my offer range
you know follow for more deal breakdowns
right yeah then we said hey that's very
good more here's another carousel three
ways to structured deal um rental deal
check wholesale one-on-one deal killer
checklist
Another carousel.
Done.
That took a minute and twenty seven
seconds, right?
Oh, my gosh.
Here's the kicker.
So then I said, hey,
give me ten topic ideas for Instagram
posts.
He gave me ten different ones.
I said, please.
And this is the important part.
You got when you're doing like you want
consistency, you want to take the image,
paste it, do a copy,
paste it in here in your.
your chat and use that as a reference.
So then it uses that same image and
it tries to recreate the same brand and
voice.
So I said,
please create images for your top five
recommendations on topics using the same
brand, voice, and tone.
So then here's post one.
I hope you're all taking notes because I'm
about to take some notes right now.
I'm giving some game right here.
Oh, wow.
You save these.
Now imagine you, Nathaniel,
as a business owner, you dedicate,
this was only fifteen minutes,
you dedicate one hour a week to say,
I'm going to sit down,
I'm just going to turn out as much
content as I want, I can organize it,
save it, download it,
put it into a folder on my phone,
and literally I'll just go out and every
day my task is to drop my Instagram
post.
Of course there's
automations that you can use i know gohan
level has automation in scale like larry
culture we're doing automation aided like
top to bottom so even if you have
something like this where you're saying
hey we want to um we have the
posts that we want larry culture could
definitely automate the post that you
already have that's probably stuff low
cost
So, yeah, man,
we try to do things the hard way,
and then we can scale back and find
the easier way to do it.
Yeah,
because you get more reason that way.
So what's the problem that you use for
the carousel again?
For the carousel?
Oh, yeah.
So all it is is just saying...
I like to take this image,
this concept from one post to a carousel
of four images or whatever number that is
with the same brand and tone,
all related to the same topic.
Please generate all four images.
And it creates all of them.
That's it.
And then, of course, if you want to,
let's say you want the description of how
it should be worded on Instagram,
you then take these same images,
paste them in here.
You can paste multiple images in your chat
and say, I'm posting this to Instagram.
Help me out with the description,
draft description.
And there you go.
Copy and paste that.
That's your description for your post.
And then, oh, so you said just add,
they can get the caption created too at
the same time?
yep just paste it in ask it for
as you would do right now i could
literally make hundreds of stuff um in the
matter of minutes just by having the right
prompts so this is where these guys do
these faceless channels then oh yeah well
So this stuff.
Yeah.
I mean, if you want to do it,
we've shown like the lo-fi Larry culture.
That's so, that's so easy.
Like that's, I do that for fun,
but here you go right here.
You copy and paste this.
This is your,
it's got the hashtags already in there.
You paste that into Instagram images.
That's it.
I like it.
So
It doesn't have to be hard, people.
We can't just go to AI and be
like, hey, make me this.
We got to be very specific.
This is insane.
What are we doing, people?
Who's reading this?
I don't even know what they're asking.
Nobody's reading this.
We can't.
And then, like, you got to, I mean,
you have a phone number.
That's cool.
But, like, nobody's reading that.
It's too much information.
So, basically, you would have to say,
you know, cut down on the prompt,
basically.
Yeah.
We're going to just have to consult with
you, man.
What is that?
The admin.
not sure what happened that was crazy but
we're back so you were frozen just now
yeah that was weird i think i like
lost internet or something happened but
like i didn't lose internet anyways we're
back hopefully that was a quick recovery
up there on the which one on the
that marcus garvey oh yeah yeah man
I grew up on that.
Like, so back, funny backstory.
My parents were from Jamaica.
My parents had a plaque that we've always
had in our house since I was a
little kid.
I think they probably got it before I
was even born.
Yeah, because they got it.
They got it probably when I was like
one years old.
Marcus Garvey died in like nineteen eighty
seven.
And he was a huge figure in Jamaica.
And so they had this plaque at home.
And they gave me the plaque and my
son broke it.
It's crazy.
But the cool thing is, yeah,
I know that was insane.
The cool thing is they actually,
so then the cool thing is they actually
revealed like, oh no,
we had two of those plaques because one
was given to my mother.
One was given to my dad.
And I was like, oh, okay, snap.
And I told him, like,
how much I always looked at it in
our home as a sign.
Like, you know, it says one God,
one aim, one destiny.
Up you mighty race.
You can accomplish what you will.
And I always looked at that.
You know,
imagery is important in the home.
I told him the importance behind it.
And they actually got it printed out for
me.
So I have it framed in my office.
Yeah, man.
Marcus.
Thank you.
So should I get a mic as well?
I mean, you got a nice mic.
This is just like a hat.
I'm going to get my hair done.
I don't know what.
I got a mic, I got a camera.
Let's see if I'm going to get the
lighting.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm changing.
and the cool thing is like you could
plug your headphones into the mic i have
low wired headphones and you can actually
i can hear myself because with the mics
you can't you can't really hear yourself
if you're working through a different
speaker like headset right so if i'm
directly in here i can hear myself and
then output coming from the computer i can
hear as well
it's like sleek it's just like it's not
really noticeable so it's just a cool
setup man so all right it's up to
this because i was i was giving monica
props on the travel business but as i
when i scrolled in to this frame i
was i was thinking like monica's about to
be traveling like
like a retreat that's like the first thing
that popped in my mind but then i
started reading i'm like travel business
like what's actually going on so monica
does need to clean up the message
messaging like what is being offered like
what are we doing here make that at
the forefront but i like the style i
like the imagery it's less than the other
one
Exactly.
If the imagery can stay consistent as far
as that pink, gold kind of look,
that's where you want to throw in that
brand tone.
Monica's going to want to copy and paste
that.
And then she could be like, all right,
well,
I want different types of content with the
same image, man.
And that's literally what your brand is.
It's that repeatable, noticeable content.
So cool stuff.
I see a lot of this, like something,
something happens.
I think I even look into it.
Yeah.
Like people, this is,
this is kind of confusing.
I think I was looking at,
let's not play that.
But like,
I was looking at this part where like
something happens,
I guess these people climb the Empire
State Building.
Yeah.
So like people take like a viral thing
and they'll use AI and kind of put
some messaging in it.
I don't know.
I'm not a fan of this one.
It's like, eh, it's a little confusing.
I know when there was a couple ones,
like there was one,
the guy that did the selfie at the
basketball game where he ran out into the
court.
Like a lot of people switched that up.
That was funny.
That was cool.
Cause it was like, all right.
Can you show that one?
Can you find that one?
Let me see.
I'm also Jamaican,
so I'm eating a piece of bun.
Let's see here.
So my brother, Gabriel Coleman,
he's a mortgage broker.
And he's been doing a lot with AI.
So let me pull up his stuff first.
And then I'll just make sure that it's
there.
Because this is like social media.
So I don't want to be putting everybody's
stuff out there.
So I'm just going to go straight to
the post I saw.
He does a lot.
I need to talk to him.
Because he does a lot with AI.
And I feel like he does do too
much information.
But then he does some posts that are
really good.
Yeah.
Maybe we bring him on and kind of
talk to him about that and show him
a little tutorial,
but he's been doing like a lot of
his posts around lending and mortgage
loan.
Oh, what do you call it?
I forgot the exact term,
but he's a mortgage loan officer.
Yeah.
Whatever,
whatever mortgage loan officers do around
it.
And he did put like,
He was one that put like one of
those viral clips.
Here it is.
All right, cool.
I found it.
Let me just share this image.
So here it is.
So like the guy that ran out on
the court did a selfie.
So he's like doing it as himself.
It's like, I didn't run on the court.
I came with the game plan.
Like, that's dope.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's catchy.
It's pretty cool, you know?
Again, way too much information down here,
Gabe.
We got to clean that up.
Make it simple.
This, not too bad.
This is very small.
But you get the point.
What's the best recommendation?
Just keep the stuff bold and keep the
offer clear and just contact info.
That's it.
yeah okay like here's the other one like
they got selfies on the court you should
have a game plan boom like literally all
of this up here this is so much
i would say just like this portion could
just be like the logo and then the
social handle
okay then like just let it like just
to keep it clean you know what i
mean like right because you already got
people's attention it's like oh that's
dope like put this in a put all
this information in the comment like
comments you can you can do like um
go to the comments for more information
boom and then you put your details in
the comments you know what i'm saying
Yeah,
you get them to stay longer on the
post as well.
So that also helps.
This aesthetic up here is like real clean.
It's perfect.
Yeah, it's perfect.
In fact, that should be the whole thing.
That's it.
Yeah, just the top portion.
And then all the information in the
comments.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we're definitely going to get Gabe on.
Again, I like his stuff.
I don't want to have his social media,
but there you go.
Just clicking through his stuff.
Yeah,
we could definitely do some more
consistent.
Like, yes, the colors kind of change.
Like, you got green and blue,
but then you got this color.
You guys just stay real consistent like
that.
The logo down here, it changes.
You see?
Yeah, it's different.
So you got to keep it consistent.
So I already know what he's doing.
He's going through and he's telling it
like, all right, do this.
And then he might be going through back
and forth chatting with the AI to change
wording because then, of course, wordings,
that could be inconsistent.
And then as it adjusts the words,
it changes the image.
And that's the thing.
If we stay super simple on the wording,
the AI doesn't have to focus on that
much.
Okay, let me write that down.
The top images are perfect.
This is good.
Yeah, he does really good with his images.
And it looks like him, too,
so that helps.
Mine sometimes is all over the place,
you know.
They have a guy that doesn't even look
anything like me.
I like this way he's dressed up as
the doctor.
That's funny.
You know, I like that.
it's like medical professions you know i
should get him on the um on the
call too because that is true yeah because
that you know you know one of the
many ebooks that i created and look at
the engagement he's got people liking
people are commenting it's good yeah so
You might have to send that to me,
by the way.
Yes, definitely.
Back to this stuff, like, man, we got,
we're just all over the place, people.
Here we go, another one, like, man, we,
ah, there's too much information.
This is not, it's not too bad,
but the right here,
it's all over the place a little bit.
Labyrinths on the rooftop, okay.
Hmm.
I need to, I still don't know.
I know it's an event.
I don't have no idea what the event
is.
Right.
You don't even know.
Yeah.
You don't even know who's the performer.
If there's a performer, you don't know.
I'm glad you said it's a porn because
I thought it was like a business mixer.
No,
it looks like it's going to be an
event.
Because it's just this black brilliance.
That's the thing.
I saw networking opportunities and my eyes
gravitated toward that as a networking
event.
And there's art,
there's live entertainment,
like entrepreneur and finance panel.
I'm not sure what I'm getting into.
so it sounds like a mixed a motley
mix of different things in one it's all
good we're not hating we love our people
oh yeah given pointers you just yeah
they're really giving free game
yeah what about that one was that a
menu oh man say what's that this is
also we got we guys do like a
reaction just like like aside from tech
thursday just going through and yeah you
could do that at any time because i'm
going to use the deal analyzer the real
estate dealer have to go go through a
hundred deals so um
Yeah, we could definitely do that.
I think we should just be on this
all the time together.
That's it.
Pull people in as we need.
That's live streaming.
This is good.
That's a good one.
I like this one.
It's video.
It's got the cool logo.
It's clean.
This is kind of funny.
Again, like taking viral moments.
websites.
A hundred dollars.
All right.
This is art.
This is what I saw.
I was like, come on, y'all.
DJ Mr. Food and Music.
Shout out to you.
Because I don't know.
That might be a niche market.
You DJ and you provide the food.
Yeah, I think, I think,
I think that it will work.
He's the, he's the entertainment,
the food.
He's the whole package.
Boom.
Vertical integration.
So why would he put will beat any
price?
I wouldn't have put that.
I mean, is it?
Or is, wait, wait, hold on.
It's not even,
it might not even be like an event.
It's just like him showing his stuff that
he does.
Well, I don't know.
I don't see an event date or anything.
I like how you mentioned that.
Yeah, it's a little confusing.
Well, it says catering events.
Events.
All DJ and catering events.
that's a that's a um that's a flyer
for services basically follow me it's
definitely interesting i i definitely want
to see make sure he got some reviews
because i mean it's a tough service food
food in itself like people are very
critical about food they are dj we're very
critical about dj's entertainment so like
want to make sure you definitely have some
real strong reviews follow it up like you
know i got a five-star review rating you
know he has a whole social media carousel
with like the the food that he made
and a dj live event that he's done
yeah exactly we need to see it we
need to feel it we need to experience
it you know because i mean i'm feeling
this food even though i know it's ai
but
Because you like wings, right?
That's what it is.
Man, don't hate on the meat lovers, man.
That's the thing.
He puts the food out,
but then I'm like, man,
I know it's AI.
I really want to see what the food
look like at your event.
Because I'm not just going...
I know that I'm definitely not paying for
that.
So what am I paying for?
And you're right.
That's where the carousel comes in where
it's like, all right, boom.
Here's what I offer from a food
standpoint.
There's some pictures of my food that I
actually do.
There's the menu.
And then from a DJ standpoint,
it's my setup.
It's people dancing.
It's how I get down.
And he could even drop it in the
comments, like links to all of that.
with the yelp the food reviews the menu
yeah comment just like book me go to
music yeah can you blow up what's in
the comments right now let's see what he
said okay i don't know what i'm trying
to see something i love our people man
i
Joanne says,
I don't know what this is on the
right-hand side of the graphics,
but it looks delicious.
Shout-outs to Joanne.
Joanne's just like, yo,
give me a plate of fries and whatever
that is on top of it.
And then he replies, loaded fries.
I mean, is that his only menu?
I mean,
he's going to have to talk more.
Is it just these two things,
or is it bar food?
Is it just the fries and the wings?
know that's a great combination food and
music but some people won't come you know
think that and we're not hating we're just
sharing some games but like if i'm looking
at it i would like to know if
there's a menu what what uh or is
these the two items only you know
Then you would have to specify, like,
when they say Wingstop,
you know you're in wings.
You feel me?
You know, when you say, you know,
Mediterranean,
you kind of have an idea that it
might be a salad falafel.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's just me.
I don't know.
Yeah, it's going to be important.
Sure.
You know, whatever.
What's the name of that handle?
We're going to.
I'm going to take Don to one of
these places so he can get some of
the wings or whatever the other side thing
is.
The loaded fries, yeah.
Yeah, loaded fries, right?
Some loaded fries.
What's we got here?
Favors.
This one, I mean, this is eye-catching.
Cleaning floors.
It definitely catches your eye.
If they could throw their logo on top
of there, that would be cool.
That would be cool.
Is it one of those floor cleaner kind
of job?
Yeah.
Conquest cleaning.
Oh, sorry.
Is it?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I guess.
So that's the guy.
So that person,
I guess that's actually Corey Joseph.
That's actually the business owner.
He did like an AI avatar of himself.
That's good.
Oh, yeah.
I would say just throw in a user
free editor like CapCut and just throw a
logo at the end of that.
That's a solid good job.
Yeah, it's not bad at all.
I like it.
How can I build one of those avatars?
That's what I want to know.
Actually, it's got a logo right here.
TikTok AI cast.
Oh,
so I could do it right off TikTok
then.
Yeah.
What else we got?
Insurance agent, business card.
Definitely do more.
Even for the cars,
I would put a little bit more personality
on it.
You know what I mean?
I would say, what was her business?
Insurance agent.
Insurance agent that specializes in houses
and airplanes.
I put a little bit more specific so
people could see it.
Exactly.
Let's do something live.
We build in public.
Oh, you know what's dope?
I hope she doesn't take offense.
You think?
Nah.
I know what you're going to say,
Nathaniel.
You're going to be like, just do it.
But we're going to do this live.
That's it.
I'm ready.
Real quick.
And you take this from a...
It's hard to... Clean... Flyer...
For social...
Again, paste the image in.
Provide a prompt.
You don't got to proofread and all that
fun stuff.
We're literally just saying, hey,
we want to make a flyer out of
this, right?
Now, here's the question.
I know you're going to say just do
it.
I feel a little weird about that, though.
What if I just take this and I
just drop it in here in the comments?
You think she'll be cool?
I don't know.
Sometimes...
I would have to like go in and
take a look at the profile of the
person first.
Like if they take themselves way too
seriously,
they might be taking everything as a
defense.
I would, if you dropped it in mine,
I would be like, dude, thanks a lot.
You know, where can I get more?
Let's work together, you know?
Yeah,
but I feel the fact that she put
the business card already kind of tells
you she takes herself way too serious.
We answered our own question right there.
I love people.
I have business cards,
but they're somewhere.
If we did it with Cole,
he'll love it.
He finds it all.
He's pretty cool.
Yeah.
You know that
the one thing i do like as a
trend i see on my facebook every now
and then it's like oh my gosh yeah
there it is that's insane that's clean
yeah it brings it more vibrant there's
more life to it hey now i really
want to give it to her because that's
it's not like that's dope yeah give it
to her let's see what happens
Just drop it.
No comment.
That's the thing about life sometimes.
She's getting publicity free.
It's cool to do good things.
You got to put your name on it.
Larry Culture did it.
By the way, guys,
Donville is a night owl, clearly.
And I shut down at like nine thirty.
So it's like.
Even though I will turn in a pumpkin
right on camera,
I'm going to still rock it out.
Oh, wait.
I never.
Never asked.
What county do you live in?
Brevard.
OK.
To meet more people.
I do reviews on your content that you
post.
I don't think you should say that.
I'm interested in local businesses.
Oh, my God.
Oh, man.
support?
There we go.
Interested in supporting local.
Ah, my typing's off.
All right.
Have you read the rules?
Sure.
Yes.
I have not read them.
What are the rules?
Don't say any bad things to other people.
That's it.
Don't say.
Right.
When you see a post, show some love.
Okay, I'm showing love, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Okay, cool.
Let's show love, right?
Yeah, we showing some love.
Love it.
Oh, so it's posted,
but I guess it's pending until I'm
approved.
So cool.
It's all right.
Shout out to Carrie.
Yeah, man.
Thank you for sharing your business card
and being able to see how we could
best work together.
She might need a website, you know?
So we might be able to do that.
Yeah, you never know, man.
That's how life is sometimes.
Oh, yeah.
That's some other folks in here.
Oh, yeah, I know, Heidi.
Hello, Heidi.
Cool.
See, like, those videos, they really just,
like, win.
Yeah.
This definitely catches my attention.
This is cool.
A little dated.
Oh, okay.
You had like that.
I was with you until I messed up
green screen.
But it's all good.
I love the effort.
Yeah, the effort.
Next time,
just make sure you have a regular
background and it'll look real nice.
Yeah.
Oh, this is dope.
What?
That's dope.
I like that.
You did a good job with that.
I like this.
See, this is perfect.
This is the background right there.
Just got to make sure it's like a
flat background and you won't have that
weird effect.
And then sometimes when people are doing
stuff against the backgrounds,
like you're too close to the wall,
if you step,
just take a step out from the wall,
it does help with that whole green screen
effect.
Okay.
What is this?
On a streak?
All right.
We just got to add some more context.
We have no idea what you're doing.
What are you talking about here?
This is cool and all, but like...
That was loud.
So this is like a full-out commercial.
We got a voiceover.
Yeah, it's a full-out commercial.
Yeah.
I'm guessing they might have paid a
freelancer.
I would say this is probably like
freelance work or they might have had
somebody like a family member do it.
It's cool,
but I'm not going to say but.
It's cool.
No fluff income.
start over building come rise above okay
we just gotta know what you're doing i'm
not sure what you're doing here right
right so basically just say what you're
doing and the call to action you can
do that on a flyer right so i
love our people here man this is a
yo it's number love man like people gotta
know nathaniel i laugh at everything
Oh, yeah, me too.
I laugh at myself.
I don't really care.
My man Kev.
My man Kev from the food spot.
He popped in and gave us great flames.
Like, come on, Kev.
What we doing?
Oh, Kev.
Kev wrote you something?
Oh, he wrote on that.
He wrote on that.
He put a fire emoji on that.
Like,
Just showing love.
That's all you do.
Showing love is good.
That's a big deal.
Okay, so after school enrichment.
Now, this is a perfect example, right?
This is a great service because we need
more.
We need more mentorship programs,
especially around behavioral stuff.
How do you present yourself in public?
How do you build confidence?
So important.
I'm talking about like
From kids that, you know,
that live in two-parent households,
great upbringing,
that's still something that's challenging
to really build, you know?
So the need is there.
We just got to get crisp on this.
Like, man, like, oh, man.
What's her name?
Kat?
Yeah,
we just got to get real crisp on
this because I love the mission.
You know, you're rich in girls,
first to third grade.
Those are very formative years.
you're doing,
it looks like you're doing group or
one-on-one.
I don't, I don't know.
So that's like, if I'm,
if I'm having questions,
there shouldn't be questions.
It means you should have answers.
Like, so is this one-on-one mentorship?
Is this group members, mentors,
mentorship?
Like I should know that the times a
week are definitely there.
Um,
And then how long are the sessions?
Because, you know, with kids, oh, well,
I guess it shows right there,
three to six.
Dang, that's a long time.
Three to six?
How does it work?
Is this like daycare?
I can drop them off and go run
a suit?
You know what I'm thinking?
Like,
can I drop them off and go run
a suit?
Just quick shopping area real quick and
come back?
Do the parents have to be there?
Hmm.
Pretty long sessions.
A lot of questions are popping up.
And I might be right,
I might be wrong.
So it could just be that she's doing
multiple sessions between three and six.
You can schedule them.
Or it's a three to six block,
which is highly unlikely.
That's a long time.
So, yeah,
we just need to clear it up as
far as, like, is it one-on-one?
Is it group sessions that are forty-five
minutes?
Is it by appointment?
How do I schedule an appointment?
Just answer all the questions.
Like, that's the best.
I guess that's the...
balance of it being able to answer all
the questions without all this information
being very crisp because i mean like this
down here is great but the only thing
that matters bless you the main thing that
matters is like you have fifteen years of
experience so right you gotta put you
gotta highlight what you
This is important down here.
Certified educator, youth mental health,
first aid certified,
like that's important.
Boom, boom.
So we would just put that on the
top.
Yeah.
Why don't you make one for her?
Yes, that's a good one.
Yeah, we like those causes,
so we'll make one for you.
Let's do a new chat.
Give me one second.
I'm still here.
I think we should definitely highlight all
of, and like you said, highlight what her,
you know, it's fifty years of training,
you know, she's a mental health, whatever,
you know, whatever those highlights are,
we want to see them.
I won't say front and center.
So that's another important thing about AI
is that you understand the English
language.
That is the new form of code.
So being able to articulate what your
intent is and explain that is super
important.
That's the difference between, you know,
getting frustrated like man say i don't
work or you being like oh like this
works wonders you know so it goes prompts
down and again luckily ai doesn't you know
my spell check could be kind of bad
but it gets it gets what i'm trying
to say
So we provided the image and we said,
please recreate this flyer,
but make it social media ready.
So that's going to be important.
Like when you're making these flyers,
don't say, hey, I just want a flyer.
When you say social media ready,
AI already knows like, okay,
I'm not going to put a whole brochure
in social media.
So like literally, yeah,
that saves you a lot of headache just
saying like, hey,
I'm using this for social media, hint,
hint.
Let's make it nice and easy to digest.
Yeah.
And I just say,
make sure the offer is clear and the
experience is emphasized.
So it's going through the description.
It's trying to understand what the actual
offer is that she's doing.
It's already scanned through the image,
looked at her.
for certifications,
the fifteen years plus experience,
all that stuff.
Before you go further,
what was that thing that you said before?
Besides making the offer clear and
basically a good call to action,
what was the thing that you were talking
about before?
Oh, it being social media ready.
Social media ready.
Yeah.
OK, so still a lot of information,
but I think it's because
She had so many offerings,
but I guess it's still got the same
information.
It's just a little cleaner.
Okay.
So I'm just going to say,
and create a minimalist version for social
media.
I do like how it brought...
So it did bring her experience to the
top.
You see how it did that?
Can you blow that up a little?
Yeah, let me... I'm doing another prompt,
but let me blow up this up.
There we go.
So, like,
see how before her experience was, like,
down here with a huge paragraph.
Right.
And I was like, very clean, crisp, like,
certified educator.
This is good.
You know, building strong girls.
I don't think that was there before.
Oh, no, it was.
It was there?
I'm looking at it.
See, so before.
It was smaller.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then a lot.
It was very text heavy.
So yeah, a lot of text.
I think this is still a lot of
text.
It's less though.
I really like this clean approach to the
spark, shine, grow plan.
And it puts her up there too.
It puts her picture up there,
which is really good.
People are buying you at the end of
the day.
They're not buying your service or your
business.
They're buying into you.
Like they're investigating you.
So she looks like a lady that will
be a good investor.
Yeah.
man,
I hope they don't block me from this
thing.
I'm like,
this guy comes on here and he like,
he takes,
instead of looking at people's flyers and
buying their business, he just keeps,
he creates new flyers for them.
I hope that's not.
I don't think anybody's going to worry
about that except for, you know,
somebody that's not as innovative or
thinking outside the box.
I think,
I think what you're doing is legendary.
Oh, so,
So it did reduce the information a little
bit, which is good.
So before this is version two, the top,
I love the top down here was a
little bit much, but then version three,
even better.
Look at that.
Hmm.
I like it a lot better.
So let's drop this.
Yeah.
We got to do this earlier,
so we can have a lot more time.
I love it.
Yes.
I'm going to like.
I'm going to comment.
Boom.
I would also add that enroll now in
the middle of the offering that she has.
if you look at the new oh yeah
the bottom yeah yeah and then yeah like
the roll now is much bigger but yeah
if it was like even like down here
it's cool but he has a little too
far at the bottom yeah
In fact,
I'll probably put spots are limited and
all that at the banner on top.
What is that?
Yeah,
move the whole banner to the top of
it.
Yeah, that's what I do.
Yeah, you want that.
Nice.
So, hope y'all appreciate it.
This is good.
Yeah, so we went from that to this.
And again,
this is all your twenty dollar a month
plan.
Hmm.
Do a lot with it.
All right, y'all.
So let's wrap it up.
Thanks, Nathaniel,
for joining me on tonight's stream.
We definitely got to do this again for
sure.
Thanks, man.
Yeah, I love it.
I love it.
And of course,
my camera's going to be amazing.
As clear as mine.
It's going to be as clear as yours.
You know,
you're trying to get me to get a
mic.
We'll see.
It might sound good.
Sounds real good.
So, yeah, man, thanks for bringing me on.
I mean,
that was a lot of good game,
free game to those folks that are
struggling with getting the right message
across because the right message is what
gets you the leads, gets you the deals.
And I'm learning that every day, you know,
the right messaging.
So.
Exactly.
As long as we're fluent on AI,
we understand it.
We're ahead of the game.
Yep.
And Layer Eight Culture is doing some
magnificent things.
So stay tuned as you watch also the
real estate deal out.
He's doing amazing things.
Let's get it.
Indeed.
Thank you, sir.
We are out.
All right.
Peace.
Have a good one.
Yep.
Have a good night.